y hoy en día las tasas de fertilidad
bajaron vivimos en centros altamente
urbanizados tenemos mayor aceptación de
la diversidad familiar y en medio de
todo este contexto integramos animales a
las familias humanas como nunca lo
hicimos hasta ahora y lo mostramos
públicamente además esto se va a ser una
dirección este bidireccional
dt de beneficios básicamente no nos
sentimos mejor y ellos se sienten mejor
habla de usted de la dificultad de crear
nuevas familias que la natalidad ha
bajado y ha aumentado también la
necesidad que tenemos de vivir
acompañados de mascotas tras la pandemia
tras los encierros por el cob y 19 si
durante el confinamiento se vio
incrementos en la tasa global de
adopciones de animales en todo el mundo
y de todas maneras si siempre conviene
recordar que los seres humanos
convivimos con animales desde mucho
antes de que existieran las ciudades
actuales o la urbanización actual no
desde el período paleolítico somos el
mejor amigo del perro pero mejor amigo
del hombre y convivimos juntos incluso
también hay muchas evidencias de
vínculos parentales con perros desde la
prehistoria por ejemplo este algunas
pinturas rupestres en cavernas o
entierros que se han hecho de perros
entonces a veces tendemos a pensar que
este es un modelo
una forma vincular ligada a la
modernidad cuando lo lea tenemos
evidencias de que desde hace muchísimos
años miles de años nos vinculamos así
con ellos y sin embargo marcos cada año
se alerta también que aumenta el
abandono de perros y existe una polémica
sobre el gran impacto ecológico que
tiene también el acaparamiento y
abandono de mascotas qué opinión tiene
usted al respecto si hoy la tendencia es
a pensar en una única salud es decir
para que los seres humanos estemos sanos
los animales tienen que estar sanos y el
ambiente tiene que estar sano ese es el
concepto de una salud un bienestar de la
organización mundial de la salud y no
podemos descuidar a los demás que
convive con nosotros con los demás que
convivan con nosotros en el planeta si
queremos estar sanos
si marcos también se habla muchas veces
de la terapia asistida con animales como
ayuda a las personas para afrontar y
recuperarse de ciertos problemas como
enfermedades cardíacas el cáncer y los
trastornos mentales también está
cobrando más importancia
si así es esto se basa en la
implementación de animales en modelos
terapéuticos que están esté avalados y
validados y conoce una forma nueva y
diferente si no es en los tipos de
terapia sea psicológica terapia
ocupacional en esos abordajes incluir
animales es una gran corriente que se
llama intervenciones asistida con
animales y en paralelo también tenemos
más evidencias sobre los beneficios de
la convivencia con animales beneficios
que surgen espontáneamente con el perro
que tenemos en casa o con el gato que
tenemos en casa es decir fuera de
contextos terapéuticos aún así tenemos
estos beneficios que decíamos al
principio no convivimos con ellos porque
nos hacen sentir mejor porque nos
aportan beneficios a nuestro bienestar y
procuramos que ellos también los tengan